SPEAKER: One thing
that makes Google Cloud
production ready
and ops-friendly
is the broad range
of management,
monitoring, and alerting
tools that it comes with.
While tools are no
magic wand and do not
replace DevOps or
SRE practices, you
should really watch this
video to better understand
what they're all about.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now, before I start talking
about specific tools,
let me mention that
these products work
best in the context of a
team applying SRE or Site
Reliability
Engineering principles.
There is not enough
time to delve into this,
but you'll find links to SRE
literature on Service-Level
Objectives, or
SLOs, error budget,
and blameless postmortems in
the video description below.
The Hello World for DevOps
tools is arguably the ability
to collect, read, and parse
logs across a distributed
infrastructure involving
multiple products.
Cloud Logging stores logs
across all Google Cloud products
and provides you with
search, monitoring,
and alerting capabilities.
It also comes with an API
to ingest custom log data
from any source.
Because it is a fully
managed service,
there are no hard
drives to provision
or partitions to resize.
And it can ingest application
and system log data
from thousands of
sources simultaneously.
Even better, you can
analyze all the log data
as it arrives in real
time without having
to worry about synchronizing
your server pods
or managing time zones.
Logs are made up
of entries created
by Google Cloud Services,
third-party applications,
or by your own code.
The message carried by the log
entry is called the payload,
and it can be a simple
string or structured data.
Examples of log
entries can include
details of a compute engine
instance starting up,
a new file being
uploaded to a bucket,
a call made to a
machine learning API,
or anything that your
application writes
to the standard
or error outputs.
Each log entry
indicates where it
came from by including the
name of the monitored resource.
Using the console's Logs Viewer,
you can query logging data
and obtain a precise
subset of all the log
entries in your project.
The query will let
you find entries
for a given resource from
different namespaces based
on the log level and,
of course, by timestamp.
Note that if using the
console isn't your thing,
these queries are also
accessible from the logging
API, as well as from
the command line.
Storing logs is free for
the first gigabyte for every
project and then comes at
$0.50 per additional gigabyte.
And your alerting
policy can be set up
to trigger when your monthly
logs ingested exceeds a given
limit.
But you can also
define excluded logs
so that some are not
stored in the first place.
The logs viewer and the
logs API are powerful tools
on their own, but
you can also decide
to export your logs
to cloud storage,
to BigQuery, or to
Pub/Sub, which then in turn
redirects them to virtually
any log storage system.
Exporting logs is
likely something
that you will want for archival
or potentially legal purposes,
but also maybe to benefit
from more advanced analytics.
There is even more to
logs, but hopefully this
gives you a good sense of
what every Google Cloud
product can rely on.
So now you know how logs are
aggregated across all of Google
Cloud and how to navigate them.
If you liked this video, please
like, subscribe, comment,
share, and look forward to more
Google Cloud Essentials videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]